[Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  science  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  thank you  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  thank you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  foreign  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]